[Musik]
in korea scheint ist ja nur wenn man die
veröffentlichungen betrachtet nur
extreme zu geben
bis silvester 2017 war wird dem
weltuntergang zumindest sehr nahe
und dann braucht es eine
neujahrsansprache des nordkoreaners und
wir waren im tiefsten frieden das eine
war so unsinnig wie das andere
allerdings hätte glaube ich niemand vor
sechs sieben monaten auch nur einen cent
darauf gewettet dass ist zu einem
leibhaftigen auge in auge treffen
zwischen das öffentlich gesprochene wort
ist bei donald trump flüchtig und er
neigt ein bisschen zur begeisterung es
war gut dass die miteinander geredet
haben und wenn sie halbwegs vernünftig
miteinander ein auskommen gefunden haben
schön wunderbar und man muss mal sehen
wird zu sich geben bekannt dass
vollständige atomare abrüstung gut dass
wollten alle die ganze zeit das wort
raketen taucht überhaupt nicht auf und
das raketenprogramm es läuft ja
sozusagen separat neben dem nuklearen
und auf raketen kann man wenn man
technisch dazu in der lage ist
atomsprengköpfe bauen
man kann auch konventionelle sprengköpfe
darauf bauen und fragen sie mal in japan
fragen sie bei in südkorea ein
atomschlag ist natürlich das schlimmste
aber von raketen mit konventionellem
sprengstoff getroffen zu werden jetzt
auch nicht schön und wenn wir uns vor
augen führen wer von den beiden hat was
zu verlieren wenn es scheitert
wenn es also wieder zurückfällt in die
konfrontation
geben und sein regime haben über
jahrzehnte geübt mit sanktionen zu leben
trump wäre erstens blamiert und zweitens
ein so dichtes sanktions regime wie er
es in den vergangenen zwölf monaten
zustande bekommen hat was nicht zuletzt
auch zur gesprächsbereitschaft den euro
erwartet
das bekommt er so schnell nicht wieder
china hat die heute schon gesagt prima
jetzt könnten wir doch über die
lockerung der sanktionen werden